Kobe Bryant's emotional family tribute
three years after the crash that killed
him and daughter Gigi welcome everyone
to Entertainment Tonight Kevin Frazier's
in Hollywood where Kobe's loved ones
just cemented his legacy hey there Kev
you know Michelle I was here back in
2011 when Kobe Bryant became the first
athlete ever to have his hand and
Footprints enshrined in front of the
Chinese Theater it rained that day too
and this morning the Bryant family
including daughter Natalia who was here
12 years ago turned out as they made
that Hollywood honor permanent
[Applause]
you're an icon a legend and most
importantly the best girl dad any young
woman could ever dream of
I never my wildest dreams thought that
this would be a possibility man this is
this is dope
as you visit here for years
to encourage you to place your hand
shoes that's exactly what Natalia's
little sisters did this morning
six-year-old Bianca and three-year-old
Capri felt their father's Legacy Colby's
imprints were in storage for more than a
decade the day he made them was pretty
special Vanessa was at his side it is a
really historic moment I'm so happy for
him and Colby was loving being a girl
dad
it's all dirty
what do you think would you put your
hands in there no way huh Kobe was so
proud to be a girl dad and I can't tell
you how many people have talked about
that and what it meant to them
today's ceremony was bittersweet it
comes two weeks after L.A County agreed
to pay Vanessa and her daughters nearly
30 million to settle a lawsuit over the
sharing of graphic photos of the 2020
helicopter crash that killed Kobe and
Gigi the inspiration of Gigi is ongoing
it's incredible that her spirit lives on
at some point will you do something in
Hollywood no no never and coming
Kobe went on to win an Oscar in 2018 for
his short film deer basketball
sitting beside him during late nights he
would always be awake writing
storyboarding editing and that story
evolved into the story that we all love
and cherish dear basketball
[Music]
speaking of the Oscars Vanessa Natalya
made it a mother-daughter night on
Sunday at the Vanity Fair party you look
like a movie star have fun tonight
that's Natalya last month at New York
Fashion Week the 20 year old model is a
sophomore in college studying film how's
that how you're doing I know she's in
college now and what's it like looking
at her grown-up
90's a brilliant uh student at USC and
just the Deep dive she does in the film
World she'll share with us she's really
on a special path there
foreign